buh buh buh buh buh buh buh buh buh buh
buh buh buh buh buh buh buh buh buh Oh
grand theft auto 5 brings a new update
to the table or half of one that is it's
called ill-gotten gains hard one and
it's packing tons of goodies the most
expensive which is this 10 million
dollar gold plated jet good but before I
can show this puppy off I gotta dress
the part and tap into what else this
update has to offer this suit of mine is
so last updated thank God ill-gotten
gains brings over a hundred new clothing
options designer shirts leather jackets
studded shoes earrings the works baby
customize your own fit or choose one of
the pre my god daddy likey ah this
random guy wants to give me a lift I
guess well fine by me to ammunation
driver where you'll find not only the
new combat PDW SMG but new luxury
engravings for certain weapons soup up
your arms with luxury finishes like
Yousaf Amir wood or metal and baby do
they look great in first person as well
am i right guy
so what else is new 15 new designer
tattoos might be for you and you also
got other minor updates for instance
weapons with lock on capabilities now
allow you to switch targets and private
dances at the strip club are now topless
thank God because that was bullsh Frank
ice but was also sweet are the four new
vehicles such as the benefactor sterling
GT which is equipped with gold wing
doors hot damn mod it up some extra
lights and race exhaust good stuff hmm I
think I'm ready now I'm grabbing some
buddies and we're gonna fly high and
mighty this luk sir deluxe seats 8 and
come stacked with champagne and cigars
tell with the glass I'm going straight
to the bottle Lou Rick hey wait who's
flying the plane
you